All right.
Hi, everyone,
welcome to this week's introduction
of Programming Nanodegree webcasts.
My name is Jonah,
I'm a co-chair at Udacity and
then over there in
mountain view we have.
>> Hi I'm Anthony also co-chair here.
Yeah, cool, so we're talking about
HTML validations, CSS validation.
Why I should care about it and
how to do it?
So first off, what is HTML validation?
So when people first thought of HTML,
way back in the dark ages of the 90s,
like we can just write web pages.
But the thing is everyone wrote web
pages maybe slightly differently.
There was a general idea
of like using HTML tags but
then there are certain conventions and
things that not everyone follows.
So people came together and
they decided on a set of rules and
if your web page met all these
requirements rules it was validated and
if it didn't than it
didn't need validation.
Maybe your website still worked but
it had to meet all
the standards in order to be validated,
so why does that matter?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Why do you think HTML validation matters
Anthony, what's your perspective?
>> Well I think it
matters the same way that
programming style
matters in any language.
Why do you have to indent where
you have to indent Python?
In Python, you have to indent where
you have to indent because
the code won't work.
But that's born out of a convention
that came from C programming,
Java programming lots of other
languages that say you have
an if statement you indent, you have
a function definition you indent.
>> Right.
Ultimately those sorts of rules
that maybe don't change
what a piece of code does.
Those rules keep things consistent,
and it makes code more readable for
people regardless of whether it
says the same thing to a computer.
I think an important thing to keep in
mind is that you're always writing code
for other people as well as you're
writing code for a future degree.
>> Definitely.
Yeah, so that's actually
a huge part of it is that
making things easier to
read is important and
also like professionalism is
also a really important thing.
Imagine your website is like resident or
something, you send it into some line
and you know if you're applying
to a technical position,
they may look at your source code and
you're like!
Your indentation is all off.
You have tags that
aren't closed properly.
Maybe your website looks fine, but
if you have these little errors here and
there, it shows that you're
not careful about your code.
So it's really important for
those type of situations as well.
So I have a couple questions.
And Peter, yes you are in the right
spot for HTML validations,
CSS validations we're
going to talk about today.
And then for Abeegeef,
hope I'm pronouncing that right.
And I think he just works.
You go through the course
on you ask your website.
You'll be submitting projects.
If you want to interact with the course
instructors you can schedule one
on one's through our website and
we'll talk with you one on one.
And help you through
reviewing your code,
answering confusing questions and
whenever you submit your projects,
you'll get feedback on whether
you meet requirements or not.
If you have any further questions
you can ask us in a side window.
So let's dive in and
then I think the best, sorry?
>> I said let's do some HTML.
>> Yeah, so
actually I used one that you've created.
I'm going to start sharing my screen.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Okay.
Where is it?
Cool there you are.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Create can everybody see my screen?
>> In just black right
now the second but
you were just there in a second.
Nope I'm just seeing a black screen.
>> Black screen, okay.
Let me stop screen sharing and
start again.
All right.
You see me?
No you don't.
A lot a
>> No just a black screen over here.
>> Let me try showing the whole screen.
>> Yeah I looked at that.
I'm not finicky.
I'm also not seeing you when
you stop screen sharing.
>> That's weird.
>> Yeah I've never seen that before.
>> Mm-hm.
You see me now?
>> Nope.
>> See my screen now?
>> Nope
>> Can anyone who is watching see my
screen?
That's not Anthony.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Well, that's an issue.
>> What happens if you do it live?
[LAUGH]
>> All right, Anthony.
I'm going to close out this window.
In the mean time you can entertain
our students I'll be right back.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
All right you're back.
That's weird.
We can't hear you.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
That's very good we'll hang here
by the week It's getting bad
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> All right, how about now?
>> Yep, I can hear you.
>> All right, I guess there's two of us.
That's weird.
>> Yeah,
your evil clone decided to join too.
>> Yeah, he's probably what's
causing this whole thing.
>> All right, You see my screen now.
>> Yep.
>> Yeah all right cool.
So.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
There it is.
Turn the notification off.
All right so we have this HTML,
which, Anthony,
you might recognize, and
actually it looks fine so far.
All the colors are showing up.
Tags like mostly right but
it's a different story in reality.
So, it's pretty simple to do so
if you want to validate some HTML you
want to just select
everything copy it so
copy and then we go to our best friend,
the W3C validator.
We will validate it by direct input
which means we're just going to type
directly in less typing in just copy and
paste everything and I'll check it.
So actually went through and
completely messed this
up I noticed that when we validate it,
we have bunch of errors.
>> On 23 of them.
>> Yeah, so it's really nice.
You can go through this and you'll see
that every error gets highlighted here.
And we're going to go through and
explain what these are one by one.
So the first one is,
the element ul is not allowed as
child element of ul in this context.
So, this means you have this
tag which is an ordered list.
>> So, bulleted list doesn't
have a number un ordered.
>> Exactly so if you want to create
a list, you do this and then and
you do like li and elements of that
list and then sometimes I see a slide.
So, I'll try to create
a list within a list.
That's fine but
you have to create it as child of li.
So, let's go to our,
so this is on line 24.
So go to line, actually let's do this.
And it's cool.
Actually that's not good.
Let's not do that.
>> Hide back to review.
>> To review, all right.
How do I hide that?
>> Then back to the review
you can hide the side bar.
That helps, that's enough, cool.
So let's look at line 24 and we see
this ul here and that's the culprit.
But if we want to create another
unordered list within the list element,
we have to do it within
another list element.
We'll create li and ul here,
it really helps to be to invent things.
Then you want to create
another list in there
like this is deeper level inception and
then close those tags that's
how you get list within list.
You don't want to just
throw uls really in there
because you'll end up having problems.
So that fixes that one,
hopefully I think.
>> I think it only but
I think it sort of makes sense when
you think that a lists only
children could be list elements.
Right?
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> And then just remember that
those list elements could contain
whatever you want.
>> Right.
Exactly.
Yeah that's good way of putting
it because these on our list.
The children unless they're on
our list as very it's children.
It can't be anything but otherwise
elements it's a really mean step
parent and yeah but if you have
another list inside the list element.
They'll take whatever,
you put like images in here,
don't do that but you can.
So, for line 28,
we have another issue here.
Actually I messed everything up
because I've put some new lines and so
I'm going to re-validate this stuff
[BLANK_AUDIO]
And okay, cool.
So now I have a bunch of different ones.
So I fixed all those, and
we have some new areas popping up.
You'll see this happen.
You'll fix one error, and
maybe something that was depending on it
goes wrong or something goes right,
and it will end up fixing itself.
But now we see you don't have
any errors until line 116.
And says [CROSSTALK]
>> The weird thing about like,
the logic of code and
especially, a validation like,
things can depend on
your unintended bugs.
Which.
>> Yeah.
>> Can cause further bugs.
So it's a weird phenomenon.
>> So
I think we have some questions here.
Or are those from before?
>> Those are before.
That's just David and
Peter saying they couldn't see you.
>> Okay, cool.
Let me just throw that out.
All right.
So now, let's angle bracket
when expecting attribute
name probable cause using
right angle brackets.
So, sometimes they'll give you
suggestions of what's going wrong and
that looks like that is an issue we
are missing a right angle bracket here.
So, .HTML is really unique.
You need to make sure that everything
has angle brackets properly put in.
And make sure that every tag
that you open is closed,
unless it's the kind of element
that doesn't need to be closed.
What's an an example of an element?
I guess images tags.
>> Image tags, the language tag.
I mean those are the common lines.
>> Yeah that's about it so
we fixed that, then on line 16,
we have slash is not immediately
followed by a right angle bracket.
That was probably
the same error as before.
And then we have this error,
end tag had attributes.
We don't really understand what's
going on at this point, but
we can assume that all the errors were
fixed by that one little angle bracket.
Cool, so line 172.
We have element angle not allowed as
child of element p in this context.
So down here, cool, so
right here I made some mistakes.
It's pretty common.
You can't use angle
brackets as notation.
If you want to talk about div
tags specifically in your code,
you can't use these.
You have to use escaping characters.
Do you happen to know what escaping
characters are off the top of your head,
is it?
>> It's < for the less-than symbol.
And a semicolon after the lt.
>> There we go, so
you can see it light up.
And then ampersand gt for
the greater than symbol.
>> That's how you want to talk
about angle brackets even if you
do just one it's going
to mess everything up.
So don't do that.
>> You notice when Jonah types that less
than symbol the colors kind of mess up,
and that's because you've heard of
interpreting that using as a tag name,
and that the others that
there is an attribute.
And weird things happen.
because those last integrated
greater than symbols have special
meanings in the language.
If we want to write them explicitly
as a lesser or greater than symbol,
we need to write it differently.
And you see this sort of thing a lot
in programming for various [INAUDIBLE]
called special meaning
in different languages.
>> Yep, so
HTML's its own second language.
One of my favorite escape
characters is the backslash and
a lot of languages has
a special meaning and
if you're to actually write
a backslash you're a backslash.
Because the backslash
special meaning says
interpret the next character literally.
So you're right, the backslash just say
And then the second
backslash is the backslash
of what you want to interpret literally.
It's weird.
So you can have one, very confusing.
>> [LAUGH] I'm glad I don't have
to work in those languages.
Neat all right so let's keep going we
have a bunch of errors left to go.
Cool so on 9 we have an error
on 192 so okay.
So it looks like I says, saw,
quotes when expecting an attribute name,
probable cause equals
missing immediately before.
That's not clay right here,
because we just made a different error.
Are attribute isn't close.
So we want to have our.
Am I getting the terminology right?
This is the attribute and
this is the value?
Right, cool.
So you want to have your attribute,
no quotes, just as a word.
And have it equals and
then the value in quotes.
It can get kind of
frustrating sometimes.
Like, it's hard to remember.
But once you do these a few times
the coloring helps you, too.
So if you notice this was yellow.
You want to have your attributes be
green and your values be yellow.
The more you do this [CROSSTALK]
>> I get an error message where
>> The probable cause is not correct.
>> Yeah.
>> Which can happen with various error
messages.
Determining an error, programatically,
is actually quite a difficult problem.
>> Mm-hm.
The validater, or
even in other languages
the trace back can make assumptions
about what's causing the error.
That just might turn out to be wrong.
Sort of like when spell check
is wrong in Microsoft Word.
It is ultimately,
you take the advice but, like,
it's up to you to like,
actually determine the cause yet.
>> That's a really good point.
The most valuable information
here is the line number.
Beyond that the best guess of
the software is probably wrong.
Sometimes it's right but
you have really have to think for
yourself in order to make these fixes.
Just one of the fun parts of debugging.
>> This makes probable cause,
not 100% cause.
>> Exactly.
Probably cause.
It's not like police probable cause,
where,
I don't know where that
metaphor was going.
192.
So I think this is the same issue.
This is the same issue.
So it seems like we have four errors.
Coming from just a couple of typos
these errors can cascade and
blow up, and it's often.
>> Does it seem like a good
time to revalidate and
maybe see what we fixed at all?
>> That's probably a good idea,
definitely yeah.
>> It's usually a good idea I
think if you fix one problem
>> Run things again see what's going on.
Reveal new information or information
that you didn't notice before.
>> Yep cool.
So we only have five areas now,
which is great.
So on line 239 says stray end tag is.
So this looks like it is just a stray,
bracket or slash.
So you want to have all your forward
sashes come before your tags
in order to close the tags,
so take that out.
And we say end tag for body C but
there are un closed elements.
So this is just means that
we end our whole page.
But there is some divs or
some other elements
that hadn't been properly close,
and those come later on here.
We have an un closed div on line 219 and
these are kind of hard cause you
kind of know whats in here and
it's important to indent your stuff
because if this was
all the way over here.
Then you don't know if it's
part of the upper div, or
if it's part of the lower div.
And you can sort of go through and
search it.
But it's really easy to look at
it if it's visually indented.
So we look at, what was it?
219?
So as concepts you want to look
toward where the concept ends,
so it's here I think.
So I think we're just missing
a div at this indentation level.
You'll notice that I just filled in,
sorry go ahead.
>> You'll be able to see that, but now
that you write that in you can see how
each closing div is coming back and
indenting, sort of like the final level.
And there was that, between where
you had that missing closing tag.
That was a nice clue as to,
where the issue was.
>> Yeah, so keeping your code clean and
indented can, and they just
saw that without even analyzing it
that there was something missing.
And something you can do
that really helps is Tools,>
Selection,> Edit.
Then you go to Edit, wow, I'm
completely blanking on how to do this,
Line > Indent.
So, is that right?
No that's not right that just
indents everything one time.
There's something to do auto indent.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
There's a point indent
doing your code better.
>> Someone came with indenting tool.
Maybe I'm wrong.
>> I've been using one
if you're using ADAM.
There's a cool package
called ADAM Beautify.
>> Okay.
>> If you apply that to your code,
it just indents it all very nicely.
It's another case,
these auto-indenters of like,
take their advice with a grain of salt
because if you have got a missing tag or
something it can indent your code
incorrectly which could be misleading.
>> Re-indent.
Yeah, that's it.
Let's say I mess up on my tags here.
And then I want to put them back.
A lot of times it'll do it right.
Maybe it will, maybe it won't.
That's okay.
Use your eyes, use your brain.
And you'll notice Spline is pretty cool
in that if you have open div and want to
close it if I just type bracket and then
this forward slash it'll fill it in.
And I don't even have to do it.
So I know that there
are some open div's.
Now, it looks like there's
another open div on line 191.
Or is that the one we just did?
No, we did 219.
191 is this div class lesson.
So I think.
So concepts within lesson so
ones all the concepts I think there's
just an extra missing div here.
Now line 30 we have another lesson so
I'll go down
until his concepts are over here
are missing missing and if.
Cool.
So I think that's about right and
it's free and it's.
Cool everything stacks up nice I think
if we copy and paste this into here.
>> We might have one
extra there at the end.
Let's see what the validator says.
>> Yep, yep, stray untag,
all right, too many divs.
>> You can see how the indentation
kind of revealed that.
>> Yep.
>> Which-
>> Good point.
>> Was the big p.
So it's not actually something weird.
So there's no errors we're also
missing a closing HTML tag.
>> Where you are missing an HTML,
an opening HTML tag too I don't think
you had one up at the top there.
>> Yeah, so
I guess [INAUDIBLE] everything so-
>> I think that I have HTML5.
Maybe the HTML tag is not necessary.
>> Really?
Interesting.
>> That might be possible.
The DOC type HTML and the HTML tag
are kind of an artifact of an older age.
You might notice that pretty much
any HTML page you write will
format this exact same way regardless
of whether you declare the doctype or
whether you have those surrounding HTML
tags will still be like prior to HTML5.
Which is the current version of HTML.
There are many different flavors of HTML
and depending on which one you specified
the browser could interpret
your page very differently.
So if you look at some much
older web pages you'll
see doc types that aren't just
the standard straight HTML.
>> Interesting.
>> If you don't define a doc type and
your browser is relatively new,
you're not working on like
Internet Explorer 6 or something.
>> Yeah, I hope not.
>> The browser will assume your page
is HTML 5 and display it correctly.
That being said, usually a good
idea to put in a doc type.
At least partly because who knows when
the standards will change in the future.
>> That's true.
>> And that can at least kind of
future-proof your webpage a little bit.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> All right.
Cool.
I think that's about it.
Validate early, validate often.
And if you need some help post in the
forums ask one of us in a one on one.
Thanks so much for coming guys.
Cool.
See you soon.
>> Thanks man.
See you later.
>> Bye.